if you want to make 20 23 the year you
lose that stubborn fat the year you get
your energy back well Dr Nash and Total
Transformation the sponsors of this next
segment have the solution and the
results
Dr Nash welcome back to the show how are
you today I'm great happy 2023. here we
go 2023 is here and I'm super excited
about this because today we're talking
about your success story and your
clients success stories let's start with
you you you're beautiful you lost 80
pounds 14 years ago and you've kept the
weight off how'd you do it so I was
obese since I was eight years old and no
diet seemed to work and what I
ultimately found out is because there
was damage underneath the surface that
was driving that weight problem so the
secret for me and for my clients that
I've worked with for 10 years is going
after that damage so that the weight
loss can be long-term well let's talk
about your clients and let's start with
Jenna so Janet lost 18 pounds in 30 days
what an incredible story
yeah and if you look at that mid section
and you see just how drastically her
body changed in that 30 days as well
this is somebody that had a severe case
of covid she almost died from it she
also had a bout of cancer and after
those two bad issues right she decided
that she had to turn that that weight
problem and that health problem around
and so she did and she reached out to me
we were able to go after metabolism
things like dietary hormone problems
inflammation and the proof is in the
picture like she looks amazing she looks
fantastic and also it jumps out is five
years of diabetes medication you got her
often in 30 days it's amazing yeah yeah
it's amazing body will do it if you just
know what to do and you are the coach to
show everyone what to do let's take a
look at Kathy and the results that Kathy
had oh my gosh so Kathy was also another
one that really was struggling with a
lot of health issues as well as a weight
problem she has lupus she has
fibromyalgia she has Hashimoto's high
triglycerides high cholesterol she comes
into me with all these problems stubborn
weight around the belly she lost 25
pounds in 30 days while going on a
cruise to Alaska and a wedding in
Nebraska now these are two ladies two
beautiful ladies that we're looking at
but you've also got you have great
success with guys and let's bring up
Tim's photo and talk about Tim's success
story
oh Tim's another great one now guys
always tend to lose more but guys also
have bigger
bigger area which
which picture he did but he lost 24
pounds in 30 days he was able to kick a
daily alcohol habit that had plagued him
for years and now he's eating about 3
000 calories a day and holding that
weight loss so just incredible and one
of the key things that jumps out with
all your clients is he says it right
there on the screen his hunger and
Cravings are gone so he's not starving
all day long yeah that's a chronic
problem I have with my clients is they
struggle to eat all the food while
they're on the weight loss journey is
because it's a lot of food and they're
not hungry that's the best type of diet
to be on well that's actually like you
said the proof is in the pictures and we
started with your picture 80 pounds
you've kept their weight off these are
amazing success stories every time you
come on the show you bring a special
what do you have for us today I do so we
mentioned with a couple of these people
that they had very specific conditions
that contributed to their weight problem
we need to do an evaluation before we
start to make sure that I can help
normally it's 97 but when people say
that I'm on Las Vegas now with JC of
course we're going to bring you 10 spots
for 9.97 they're available online not by
calling my office but they sell out
quickly especially in January so if you
want that help lock it in now awesome Dr
Nash thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it but thank you so much
thank you again to Total Transformation
for sponsoring this segment for more
information visit Dr nash.com forward
slash eval or call
702-852-6888 and don't forget about the
special offer that she mentioned Las
Vegas now we will be right back